how is it that you two have never
started a movie together I want like I'm
curious has it ever been close I blame
Ashton is the Ashton's fault I don't
know Rhys thought I was weird
saw me at a party Karen I did this is a
true story none of this is true oh by
the way what was wild is for years and
years and years I was like oh man I'd
love to do a romantic comedy with Reese
for years and years and years and it's
so nice it makes sense but it's like the
schedules don't match up it's not the
right movement and then one day I get a
phone call out of the blue that is like
hey Elaine and Reese are doing this
thing together I think you should check
this thing out do you think that you'd
be great for it and I really I didn't
have to read it I should have just like
blind said yeah but I was like I stop
everything I'm doing today we're doing
it I read the script and then that's
High Praise coming from a man who hasn't
started a rom-com in 10 years I know we
brought him back you did I mean did
working with Ashley for the first time
live up to your expectations Rhys I mean
it was so fun in this perfect movie wait
what is all this Peter's not interested
in me like that is he
I feel like we should see what you and I
could be
this is a minor setback right all you
have to do is take a
chances
for the greatest script and we both had
equal parts that's a big piece of it too
I think so a lot of rom-coms don't know
how to balance and this one was just a
50 50 movie and so we both felt
responsible for making it funny and
better and endearing and real and
grounded and I'm so glad it's on Netflix
too because I feel like it's everybody
can see it everyone loves the wrong club
like I was watching this one with a
glass of wine my pizza like it becomes a
ritual you know when you sit down to
watch that's the thing about the rom-com
right right you and I tell each other
everything right always I think I may
have met someone
can I tell you something immediately the
night that Debbie and Ike spent together
after or found myself thinking about her
you have to tell her it's too late
it was funny as Neil and I would be at
home during the pandemic and we're like
just about like a good it was like a new
rom-com that I could like something
that's like because the world is like
dark enough and there's news in this and
good politics and that thing and wars
and this stuff and you're like sometimes
you just want to like be entertained and
completely disassociate and then now it
exists right exactly it's called your
place or mine and it is on Netflix
February 10th February February was that
the big draw for you to return to this
genre was that we need kind of more of
this levity it was that it was the idea
of working with the queen uh it was the
idea of working with the lean brush
McKenna who I really wanted to work with
it was also like the story of this movie
right it's about people who've been
friends for years 10 years however long
they've been friends that find this
spark that existed and I went huh I know
a thing or two about that this seems
somewhat familiar uh I think this could
be an interesting story to tell okay I
love that well it's perfect because I
feel like you two are legendary in the
rom-commer genre you go right ahead and
spend your money oh but darling and I
thought you said we should think of it
as our money
[Music]
that's my best friend
and I do want to ask you guys if your
love stories with your respective
spouses were a rom-com what would the
title of that rom-com be for you double
down
because we're talking about poker
metaphors in this movie okay double down
the ROM come with my my significant
other I think it's called No Strings
Attached or friends with benefits you
can choose the title and we both made it
and then we both lived it Reese we're
also excited about Daisy Jones and the
six I mean the trailer dropped and I
feel like it really lit up the internet
and especially because it's such a
awesome vehicle for Riley oh yeah can I
ask how you and the cast are rallying
around Riley especially after the loss
of her mother well we're really excited
about Daisy Jones and the six and
obviously you know just um there to
support Riley in every way Ashton you
have a big birthday coming up how sweet
is this birthday and really the season
of Life For You especially after you
have opened up about your own health
Journey the funny thing was that my
health thing was it was like three years
ago I woke up one day and like was
having Vision issues could hardly see
knocked out my hearing which threw off
my equilibrium and my bow balance and I
couldn't walk and I had vasculitis and
I've kind of been moved past that for
quite some time the thing I get excited
about for my birthday is my kids they
get more excited about my birthday than
I get excited about my birthday now yeah
which is like magical to like have like
they're just so stoked for my birthday
and they want me to be so it makes me
more excited about the fact that it's my
birthday I love it that they're like Dad
your birthday's coming up you know it's
your birthday and it's gonna be your
birthday you're gonna have a cake
because birthday is when you're a kid
are like everything right that's like
your day yeah and so they're just jacked
up about my birthday and I'm like what
are we gonna do well they make
everything sweeter including holidays I
feel like kids really amp up the
excitement around everything so I'm
excited for my kids for my birthday
[Music]
foreign